act of kindness acts of generosity is
how simple it is to make people feel
good I was walking down the streets of
New York City and a guy walking in front
of me his backpack opened and a bunch of
paper fell out on the on the street I
didn't think much of it I bent town I
gathered up the papers handed them back
to him and pointed out that his his bag
had opened now in our bodies as a
chemical called oxytocin oxytocin is
responsible for all the warm and fuzzies
unicorns and rainbows it's responsible
for all the warm feelings and
connectedness we have with each other
friendship love huge amounts of oxytocin
surged through a woman's body as she
gives birth this is what is responsible
for the mother-child bond oxytocin binds
human beings there are many ways to get
oxytocin one of them is acts of kindness
and acts of generosity it feels good
when we do something nice for someone it
feels good when someone does something
nice for us on this particular day I did
something for someone with no
expectation of anything in return I got
a little surge of oxytocin I felt good
he turned to me he said thank you it
feels nice when someone does something
for us with no expectation of anything
in return he felt good I walked to the
end of the street I'm waiting to cross
the street and a total stranger who
happened to be standing next to me said
I saw what you did back there that was
really cool as it turns out witnessing
an act of generosity
releases oxytocin and he felt good and
the best part about oxytocin is the more
oxytocin we have in our bodies the more
generous we become it is Mother Nature's
Way of trying desperately to get us to
look after each other I can guarantee
you that that man who witnessed what I
did did something nice for somebody that
day simply because he saw someone do
something nice for somebody that day so
what if we commit to do something nice
for someone with no expectation of
anything in return imagine what happens
at work imagine what happens at home
imagine what happens with our friends
but it must be genuine
[Music]